will you guys cover injury recovery
and the mentality to quick recovery
and advice how to find physical limit
without injury
okay so for this one
well first of all train hard
but always train smart you know don't do
things that
are going to hurt you and this is a
balance just like everything else
you have to push yourself hard enough
that you get stronger but at the same
time
you can't push yourself so hard that you
get injured so
i think that's one of the keys
another key is making sure you take
adequate rest
which of course i'm usually guilty of
not doing that being said
when you see me training every day i'm
not you know i'm not going
110 every day there are some days where
i roll into the gym and i say
yeah okay this is not a this is not a
day to push myself i'm injury prone
today
you know and so i i will taper my
workout
and i'll usually do some other kind of
intensity
but let's say i'm not going to lift
heavy weights or i'm not going to sprint
because i'm feeling tight and i don't
want to pull muscle so you just
you got to listen to what your body's
saying
another thing that i think is important
about it is you know we talked about
on the last podcast is you know changing
your goals
and constantly chasing after different
goals you know you're going for a
a deadlift and then you're going for a
mile time run and then you're going for
a number of pull-ups and you're
you're constantly kind of changing those
and i think that is a
good way to avoid injury because you're
not just
hammering the same thing over and over
and over again which i think leads to
injury now
that being said you don't ever want to
just completely
stop you know elements of your workout
you know you want to keep that's why
it's good to not go in these extreme
directions
and i'll tell you one what i think is
the most important thing for me
for being relatively injury-free and i'm
about to list all my injuries
on the next question but relatively
injury-free is that i
always work out i always work out
and i think that
when people i think when people take
extended periods of time off and by that
i think i mean
you know you're starting to get into
like two weeks three weeks maybe a month
of
not doing anything i think when people
come back
from those is when they get injured is
when they get hurt
because their body's just it's still
strong it still
thinks it can do what it did three weeks
ago
but it can't it's not conditioned for it
and that's when
that's when you get hurt uh another good
piece i think for
recovery and is the is a mobility wad
the kelly k-star
you know go to mobilitywad.com and just
look at that look at what he's doing
look what he's putting out he's got some
great stuff to heal yourself and
and square away your injuries
i think stretching i think stretching is
important but i think people take it to
an excess
and i think when you do too much of it i
think it's
i think it's causes problems um
i know so i know some some guys that
have done
extreme yoga and
i think extreme yoga is you know once
you're
once you go beyond what is normal or a
little beyond normal
you start to injure yourself and i think
that's not good i think it leads to you
know
joint laxity where your your your joints
can actually move
too much and there's not enough holding
them in place so they're
stability right right and so i think
just listen to your body
and i think that the next part of this
question will answer in the next
question
just to kind of add to that nutrition as
well like eating enough so a lot of
people especially if they're trying to
cut up or
or drop some weight and you know if
you're training for something you got to
make weight that's you know that's going
to be a little bit more specific
strategy but
a lot of times people will starve
themselves yeah i'm always telling
people like
when they're feeling negative or they're
feeling like they're injury-prone i'm
always telling people they're probably
lacking fats they're probably lacking
good fats you know
yeah so i agree with you diet is
extremely important
yeah and what like when you when you
work on this what i learned early on
and on understanding the importance of
this i think really
really helped is if you eat right after
you work out
don't don't think that you're going to
eat a meal and that's going to fuel your
workout because
like it takes a while for the the
calories to go into your system the fuel
workout it's not going to do it in like
an hour so don't eat
so go work out and then eat after so
that
those calories and in those nutrients
will help
your body recover and within that hour
that's when your body wants to recover
and wants those nutrients yes so doing
that
if you starve yourself or don't eat or
eat
very little your your muscles aren't
going to be recovered your tendons are
going to be a little bit more weak
even when you do recover it didn't take
in those nutrients yeah so
you will be way more prone i probably i
probably need to do a better job of that
as you
well i people always ask me and i i get
done working out you know at like five
or six
well maybe six o'clock in the morning
i'm done working out and i usually don't
i usually don't eat until
nine or ten you know so i probably need
to do a better job of that i'll
take echo charles's advice on that one
yeah that's
um it's funny but i have an open mind so
it's cool i can do that
yeah good in the bodybuilding
bodybuilding world that's like a
no-brainer called the anabolic window
and it's like you you can see little
jokes on it where it's like gotta jump
through that
oh he missed his anabolic window and it
shows a picture of like a guy holding a
guy dying or something yeah it's like
it's a real important thing and it helps
so much
we'll give it a shot right on